what time is it time to look at photos
of people we don't know and think things
I dyed my hair gray because I'm secure I
have never seen an episode of this
season of The Bachelor I have in the
past seen an episode of the series
itself but I have not paid attention
don't know anything about this season I
think there are two contestants left but
I don't know who and I don't know period
that's the theme of this entire channel
if you don't know the bachelor is a
reality show in which women compete for
the love and affection of one single man
because what a better way to teach women
about empowering women than to have them
compete for one natural human emotion
that should bring us nothing but joy
love in front of millions this is truly
our Hunger Games so I thought like what
I did with the presidential candidates
video recently thing I'm going to look
at some photos of the contestants for
the first time and just make up some
general assumptions based on personal
associations I have with what they look
like but this is not meant to be
negative so don't think I'm just sitting
here shushing on a bunch of ladies that
I don't know know ABC the network and
the concept of the show itself does that
enough for me let's look at these
contestants I think there's 28 of them
so we got a lot to get through well
here's the bachelor Ben Higgins he looks
like he's never put his hands in pockets
before this looks like he might have
gone swimming with the dolphins when he
was younger and like something kind of
weird and maybe like sexual happened was
one of the dolphins but it didn't tell
anyone he looks nice Amanda amanda has
had an infectious bellybutton piercing
Amanda looks like the kind of girl that
smoked marijuana for the first time in
high school and thought she was a
Maltese for like two weeks cue amber
amber looks like the kind of girl that
like very sincerely ran for class
treasurer and everyone's like yet no one
else wants it amber you can have it and
she
like yes Becca Becca looks like the kind
of girl that had some romantic feelings
for a horse until like she turned nine
and realized that's not good she'll
always have mr. Jones Brianne Brianne
looks like the kind of girl that's got a
business plan saved you Microsoft Word
on her desktop for opening an Etsy shop
of beaded turquoise songs because
brambly is that your butt crack is the
neck of your private area Polly okay
kala kala kala kala kala kala kala looks
like the kind of girl that like always
breaks her arm at every roller skating
birthday party or like any birthday
party with like a bounce castle or like
anything were you just standing Emily
Emily looks like the kind of girl that
entered a beauty pageant but like her
talent is staying her name in American
Sign Language hailey hailey looks like
the kind of girl that put a hot dog up
her butt during an intense game of truth
there at one sleepover and like no one
could unsee it Isabel is he is he's like
that kind of girl that like always
wanted to play football with the guys in
middle school like definitely a boob
popped out at one point pretty cool day
Jackie Jackie thinks that she can talk
to cats Jamie Jamie looks like the kind
of girl that's had some sort of
embarrassing incident at No Country
Buffet Jennifer Jennifer looks like the
kind of girl that in you know a very
desperate moment had to use a pack of
orbit gum as a tampon it happens Jessica
Jessica oxide the kind of girl that
really isn't above making out with an
open-minded elderly woman if it's for a
good cause Joe well Joe Joe Joe Joe Joe
Joe looks like the kind of girl that was
like born really wanting to be a Dallas
Cowboys cheerleader but like definitely
you that she was not going to be a
Dallas Cowboys Cheerleader that's okay
Pilates instructors like the Dallas
Cowboys Cheerleader of the fitness world
Jubilee Jubilee looks like the kind of
girl that's got an old yoga mat covered
in dog piss somewhere in her house lace
lace looks like the kind of girl that
still earnestly believes that she could
be an American Gladiator she's halfway
there with the name Laura Laura looks
like the kind of girl that like was
always shorter than everyone growing up
and so she's got just like so many high
school photos of like Chad or Shane the
football player like just resting their
elbow on her head or putting their hand
on her head and like she just really
wanted to be considered human Lauren lb
lb looks like the kind girl that's like
so down for going to Dave & Buster's
like how ironic and fun and then she
gets there and she's like everything is
covered in hepatitis Lauren B 1 B looks
like the kind of girl that like maybe
got her first period doing like a potato
sack race at a family's 4th of July
party Lauren H Lauren H looks like the
kind of girl that is not good at dancing
Lauren R looks like the kind of girl
that has an extensive list of things
that she can hold in her under boob area
and is very proud of it it's a very
lovely skill Lee or Lia Lia looks like
the kind of girl that just always wants
to arm herself always your legs just
stop I just asked you if you had to go
to the bathroom to Megan Megan looks
like the kind of girl that like she
loved st. Patrick's Day Mandy Mandy
looks like the kind of girl that Shops
at that store Mandy yo mouth you know
time out Olivia Olivia looks like the
kind of girl that like grew up going to
pageants all the time but really just
wanted to talk to her and that one song
like makes her saw Rachel Rachel looks
like the kind of girl that like
definitely has a selfie with Mario Lopez
as the background of her phone Samantha
Samantha looks like the kind of girl
that might get more than your average
number of UTIs Shoshana Shoshana looks
like the kind of girl but does it know
how she ended up on this show Chiara
Chiara looks like the kind of girl that
like look who's talking and look who's
talking now and like all of those movies
make her cry because just the thought of
babies is like so beautiful oh that's it
well there you go there are all of my
completely meaningless assessments of
the contestants on this season of The
Bachelor we're any of them close to what
you've noticed if you watch that show on
that I hope that you have a wonderful
day today thanks for being here with me
don't forget to subscribe
oh yeah oh hey buddy
mmm that's it I don't know good morning
it is 556 a.m. you are just so good